what tv series would each of you like to
guest star on
grey's anatomy honestly the mandalorian
would be so cool
sorry peyton that's so good can i change
yeah
hey we could we could guest star
together put us in an episode
what movie or movies have each of you
seen the most
500 days of summer so many times
i have seen inception too many times
i love that movie what do you think at
the end
do you think that he is dreaming or do
you think he's in the real world
i think he's dreaming
he's dreaming i could spend the next six
minutes talking just about that but
anyway
um do either of you collect anything
i collect uh i love to travel so any
country that i travel to i like to bring
back money
um so i have like a big collection of
all the different dollar bills that i've
collected through the different
countries nice i'll give you some
um i don't know if it's like a
collecting thing but
i like buying plugins
i make a lot of music so i enjoy buying
lots of plugins that's the only thing i
can think about got it i'm also
wondering if he's collecting money
because he's thinking at some point he's
going to be like a jason bourne
so like a suitcase filled of money
wherever he goes
that's lit that's all i need
because of the karaoke in this movie uh
what is your go-to karaoke song
someone like you by adele happy birthday
yo it works every time it's a good laugh
you're just like
yo can you queue a happy birthday and
they're like
cute i don't even need the monitor all
right just give me
um it's actually that's actually great
i've never heard someone do that and i'm
sure that would get a laugh
um no for sure uh peyton you have a very
interesting story on the way you
auditioned for this movie
um you sort of relay that to uh people
yeah so uh obviously we were dealing
with covid so
nothing was in person so it was all over
zoom um
and i was sitting here with the laptop
and i was like reading the script and
obviously
my character's shirtless for 80 of the
movie um
and right before i started it i just
said you know what i'm just gonna take
my shirt off
and i just took my shirt off and sat
there and started it and as soon as they
jumped on
i found out later that i was their first
audition um
and they were just like we're just
waiting for someone to do like what you
did i just completely made it my
own and just i just dove in i just went
for it i didn't care
uh for both of you guys for both of you
guys though
how nervous do you still get like the
night before an audition are you in your
head
a lot like do you think when you do an
audition you nail it can you sort of
talk about that
um i still get extremely nervous before
every audition like
bathroom like not to get too into it but
you know just like
everything just nerve-wracking i mean
even even though most of it's on zoom
now it's still extremely nerve-wracking
because you want to put your best
and like i never know if i did a good
job or not
because it's just so fast and
like so nervous you kind of don't know
what's going on
so that's personally
i mean i would say i don't i don't
really get nervous at all anymore
um i'm just really more excited about
doing it but
whether i got it right or not obviously
you just have no idea i mean you're just
kind of putting yourself
into this character and then throwing it
at the wall
and hopefully it's sticking or hopefully
they can move you in a direction to make
it work um but it's really just
you know you go out there and you throw
what you got and then you just
kind of forget about it because you have
no idea i have no idea
what i did if it's good or bad it's just
it's just a guessing game
yeah i've spoken to a number of
directors and some of them say
they'll know like within like a
millisecond if this person is right for
the role
it's so interesting and other people say
that other directors have said no i
really need to talk to them it's
it's just i can't imagine what you guys
go through
a lot of rejection rejection
uh myra if i'm not mistaken uh this is
your first
like big movie i'm i'm right about this
right
yes this is my first feature so
crazy to think about i am curious though
what do you wish you knew on the first
day of filming that you learned
during the shoot honestly
i just wish i wasn't you know so nervous
or so hard on myself
i just like was so in my head about it
and i was like okay i have to remember
all these things i have to do all these
things
all these you know and especially i feel
like this one's a little different
because of covet as well there was that
extra like stress of cobit so it was a
little different but
just like more like trust that you were
chosen for a reason
imposter syndrome is but like trust that
they liked you
for who you are and like you're good for
the character and just like trust your
gut and go with it
don't think too much uh for both of you
guys i love
learning about stuff like behind the
scenes or the making of a movie
what do you think would surprise fans of
the film to learn
about the making of the film i think
the thing that surprises people the most
and i'm sure peyton has a different one
is that we only shot it under in under a
month
so fast yeah what was it 20 it was like
23 day production 23 days
yeah twenty-four so fast it was it moved
so quickly that was that was my answer
like i mean the fact that
most films i mean it depends on the film
but most of them are
anywhere from 40 to sometimes 60 day
productions and ours was 23 so it was
just
every day it was like we had to be on
top of our game to be able to get
through
each day because you know some of them
went a little longer but it was
we had a time crunch how long did it
take after
getting the role uh before you started
talking to mark about mean girls
oh i'm pretty sure it came out
immediately like on set
me like the other girls would like
reference it constantly and i don't know
if it
i don't know if mark enjoyed it or found
it annoying but hey we did it anyway
but mark is iconic he's just an amazing
amazing person amazing director so
so lucky to work with him yeah mean
girls is one of the biggest obviously
that was when i talked to him about
immediately but i mean he worked with so
many people like jim carrey and matthew
mcconaughey and
there was just so much to pick his brain
about because he was just he's a legend
i mean the man the man's a legend
on that note i have to stop i'm just
going to say again congrats i know this
is going to be a big hit for you guys
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating thank you thank you so much